[Music]
hello and welcome to the pledge brexit
has become much like the
trick-or-treaters doing the rounds this
week full of ghoulish characters threats
of food shortages and seemingly still
with no end in sight the 31st of October
is here yet
despite months of promises we're still
in the EU well in honor of this chapter
in the political horror show we decided
to immortalize the key players in
vegetable form in hope that they'll do a
better job at sorting this mess out than
the pumpkin heads in the Commons now in
case you're all wondering who's on your
pumpkin Michelle not David Cameron I
know but that is scary me Kabhi Nick
John Burke he's for you and Rachel going
to get home enough with the spooky
spectacle let's get on this said
pumpkins out coming up I'm taking on the
hypocrisy of our immigration system Nick
questions the lessons learn from the
Granville tragedy f was tackling unequal
pay and Michelle asks whether we really
are becoming more hateful but first it's
Rachel not another one 2014 general
election 2015 referendum 20
sixteen general election 2017 euros 2019
and now a winter general election it
will be cold dark and wet on the stump
students will have gone home for the
holidays the franchise hasn't been
extended to EU citizens here for 16 and
17 year-olds
either did we really have to go through
this again well this is a government
without a majority and a parliament that
is stuck on brexit the only way to solve
both problems we are told is a general
election it's a high-risk strategy that
will only work if the PM wins a majority
and his own thumping mandate to drive
his former brexit through will GE 2019
be an early Christmas present for the
Tories or is it more of a gamble than a
gift
well Rachel it has sort of been a war of
attrition and I'm reminded when sadly
this country went to war in July 1914
they said it will all be over by
Christmas this time it will all be over
by Christmas we will have the general
election we will know the way we're
going I'm sure you're joking about this
argument that it's cold dark and wet
because that was the most factual
argument that I've ever heard having a
general election for not having one for
naught it assumes that people don't go
out shopping or they don't go to work
and the idea that elderly people we're
treating them like some sort of
protective it that was absolutely a
general election thought out brexit I
sincerely hope so
I sincerely hope so because all the
parties the main parties positions are
utterly clear if you want us leave the
country if you want to leave the
European Union you know what part for
which party you must vote if you want a
referendum everybody's in and the most
important thing and I don't want to rain
on Michelle's conversation later is that
this is needed to just try and calm the
country down there is an evil toxicity
which needed the boil to be lanced I
believe the general election will do it
I believe was absolutely right and I
actually said almost three cheers when
he got the vote right can we just have a
response from that from Caroline Lucas
to the only green MP who says the
general election is too
multi-dimensional to sort sort out a
binary issue let's
what Caroline Lucas has to say I think
it's disappointing because it's very
clear that a general election is not
going to solve the brexit crisis the
clue is in the name general that means
we have a whole set of issues that
people will be voting on in a general
election and if you want a specific
answer to the issue of brexit you have
to ask a specific question and that
doesn't happen through a general
election it happens through a
confirmatory ballot as we speak people
are leaving the party their party's in
droves
why will replenishing the Parliament
with those MPs who are more on message
than those who disagree with the current
as it were tendency of their parties
make Parliament any less toxic I
couldn't agree more
I mean it's Halloween we're in full
smoke-and-mirrors territory first of all
that's ridiculous Nick to say that the
time of year you do something doesn't
affect it when the weather is bad people
don't shop the house I'm not saying we
shouldn't have enough referendum for
that reason the reason we shouldn't have
around election I'm not saying we
shouldn't have an election for that
reason the reason we shouldn't have an
election is exactly what Rachel saying
it won't solve the problem the problem
is not that the house is lacking
legitimacy that it's exhausting both of
which are true it is the problem is is
that there is total deadlock on brexit
and the hope let's just play you a
little montage from Boris Johnson to
make the point that when we listen to
pledges we can't even know whether we
can take them seriously and there is a
warning that this clip does contain
flash photography
we must leave the EU on October 31st no
ifs or buts
deliver brexit on October the 31st we
should get on and get it done by October
done by October I know what you're going
to say it's not his fault today the
third topo we haven't left he didn't say
if everything goes well he said no ifs
no buts
we will leave the House of Commons votes
for us to leave if I get a deal he
didn't say that he said no ifs he's
completely lacking credibility as the
Labour Jeremy Corbyn says that this is
an election that will deliver a wider
mandate than brexit which is a wonderful
thought but it's just not reality he
said this election is a
once-in-a-generation chance to transform
our country and take on the vested
interests holding people back the choice
that this election could not be clearer
we will now launch the most ambitious
and radical campaign for real change for
that country has ever seen
that's also a fantasy the reality is we
can't launch a program of change of
redistribution of wealth of progressive
policy until we deal with brexit and the
Labour Party's message and brexit
frankly is confusing and I don't see how
an election is going to solve the
problem that everybody is fudging can
the elephant in the room okay Nick said
that everybody knows who to vote for
when it comes to breakfast today
Michelle I mean if we won't leave do we
vote for the Tories or do we work for
the brexit party well first of all I
think that there's not going to be a
clear core output to this government to
the election I don't think we're going
to end up with a strong majority I think
we going to end up again with a hung
parliament and the thing that concerns
me is I don't think we've learn any
lesson can you just develop that if we
do get hung parliament then what well
I'll explain why I think we're going to
get hung parliament and that the problem
that I have with most of this is because
we've not learnt lessons about why we
had brexit in the first place because
what you've got is you've got the
arrogance of the Tories absolutely
refusing to do any sort of leave pact
with the brexit party and for me that is
where I think this election is going to
fall down because we are all being
marginally a country of brexit ears and
with the current leave Parliament's with
a remain Parliament so what we need is a
leave Parliament and the only way you
can get that is if there is some sort of
pact
the brexit party and the toys the
tallest shouldn't be going anywhere near
northern leave seats and if you ask me
the brexit party should be leaving
you're scratching your face off this is
a weird conversation look there to fact
here number one this country will not
elect Jeremy Corbyn as its Prime
Minister and that piece of data tells
you minus 60 approval ratings worst in
history they're not an elect him is and
that is why Boris Johnson was able to
take all the risks cut he knew
eventually we'd end up here because he
knows he can't lose now good days can he
win and the key to that the elephant in
the real elephant in the room is what
will Nigel Farage do if he's at the
moment had about 10 12 percent of the
vote if that if the Tories can get 5 or
6 percent of that they win a big
majority and the key question is will
Nigel Faraj roll over by the way I
happen to think people who like the
brexit party I'm not stupid
they will not vote for a party that they
know won't win seats they will vote Tory
that's why I think Boris Johnson will
win and I think by the way your party
neither tomorrow will probably say we're
not fighting for 500 I do think it is
fundamentally wrong that the Tories
wouldn't enter into a leave pact with
the brexit party because they because in
northern areas and I'm northern so I'm
talking from those kind of things there
is I can't even explain to people that
don't get it naturally it's like inbuilt
in you it's like in your DNA they hate
the Tories I can't even like
not leaving as well don't they yeah but
what I think will happen is you'll have
a brexit Party candidate and you'll have
a Tory candidate they'll split the vote
and liberal get in anyway just briefly
it's well known that the brexit party
has spoken with you in the past as a
potential candidate what conversations
have you had about running in the
general election I have have been
approached
not that it will surprise
probably impress you but yes approach
and I've really got to work out because
to me if you asked me would I be more
concerned about a Jeremy Corbett and
government or you know what will inform
your decision I would like to see is the
Tories been realistic and accepting that
there are some northern leave seats that
they would not get in and they need to
step aside let the brexit party will
make you decide to stand as a candidate
so what will make you decide well I need
to think about what the strategy is
where they're placing candidates and I
don't think this table is saying run but
choose the right that's my home I don't
want to be a politician and they've
backside end of nowhere I just let's
turn to something a bit more serious
than the parliamentary shenanigans